can the general sort of robotics
the epitome of the robotics problem be
solved purely through learning
perhaps end-to-end learning
sort of learning from scratch as opposed
to injecting human expertise and rules
and heuristics and so on
i think that in terms of the spirit of
the question i
i would say yes uh i mean i think that
in though in some ways it may be like
an overly sharp dichotomy like you know
i think that
in some ways when we build algorithms we
you know
at some point a person does something
like yeah there's always a person turned
on the computer
a person uh you know implemented
tensorflow but yeah i think that in
terms of
in terms of the point that you're
getting and i do think the answer is yes
i think that
i think that we can solve many problems
that have previously required meticulous
manual engineering
through automated optimization
techniques and actually one thing i will
say on this topic is
i don't think this is actually a very
radical or very new idea i think people
have uh have been thinking about
automated optimization techniques as a
way to do control
for a very very long time and
in some ways what's changed is really
more the name
so you know today we would say that oh
my robot does
uh machine learning it does
reinforcement learning maybe in the
1960s you'd say
oh my robot is doing optimal control and
maybe the difference between typing out
a system of differential equations
and doing feedback linearization versus
training a neural net
maybe it's not such a large difference
it's just you know pushing the
optimization
deeper and deeper into the thing well
it's interesting you think that way but
with uh d
especially with deep learning that uh
the accumulation
of sort of uh experiences and data form
to form deep representations
starts to feel like knowledge as opposed
to optimal control
so this feels like there's an
accumulation of knowledge to the
learning process
yes uh yeah so i think that is a good
point that uh one big difference between
learning-based systems and classic
optimal control systems is that
learning based systems in principle
should get better and better
the more they do something right and and
i do think that that's actually a very
very powerful difference
so if we look back at the world of
expert systems and symbolic ai
and so on of using logic to accumulate
expertise human expertise human encoded
expertise
do you think that will have a role at
some point the
you know deep learning machine learning
reinforcement learning has been inc
has shown incredible results and
breakthroughs and just uh
inspired thousands maybe millions of
researchers
but you know there's this uh
less popular now but it used to be
popular idea of symbolic ai do you think
that will have a role
i think in some ways um the
kind of the the descendants of uh
uh symbolically i actually already have
a role so
you know this is the the highly biased
history from my perspective
you say that well initially we thought
that rational decision making involves
logical manipulation so you have some
model of the world expressed in term
in terms of logic uh you have some query
like
what action do i take in order to for x
to be true
and then you manipulate your logical
symbolic representation to get an answer
what that turned into somewhere in the
1990s is uh
well instead of building kind of
predicates and statements that have true
or false
uh values we'll build probabilistic
systems where
uh things have probabilities associated
with probabilities of being true and
false and that turn into base nets
and that provided sort of a boost to
what were really
you know still essentially logical
inference systems just probabilistic
logical inference systems
and then people said well let's actually
learn the
the individual probabilities inside
these models
and then people said well let's not even
specify the nodes in the models let's
just put a big neural net in there
but in many ways i see these as actually
kind of descendants from the same idea
it's essentially instantiating rational
decision making
by means of some inference process and
learning by means of an optimization
process
so so in a sense i would say yes that it
has a place
and in many ways that place is or you
know
it already holds that place it's already
in there yeah it's just by different it
looks slightly different than it was
before yeah but but in some there are
some things that
that we can think about that make this a
little bit more obvious like if i train
a big neural net model to predict what
will happen in response to my robot's
actions
and then i run probabilistic inference
meaning i invert that model
to figure out the actions that lead to
some plausible outcome like to me that
seems like a kind of logic
you have a model of the world it just
happens to be expressed by a neural net
and you are doing some inference
procedures some sort of manipulation on
that model
to figure out uh you know the answer to
a query that you have
it's the interpretability it's the
explainability though that seems to be
lacking more so
because uh the nice thing about sort of
expert systems
is you can follow the reasoning of the
system that to us
mere humans is somehow compelling it
it would it's just uh i don't know what
to make of this
fact that uh there's a human desire for
intelligence systems to be able to
convey
in a poetic way to us
why it made the decisions it did like
tell a
convincing story and perhaps that's like
um
a silly human thing like we shouldn't
expect that of intelligent systems like
we should be super happy that
there's intelligent systems out there
but uh
if i were to sort of psychoanalyze the
researchers at the time i would say
expert systems connected to that part
that desire for ai researchers for
systems to be explainable
i mean maybe on that topic do you have a
hope
that sort of inference systems of
learning
based systems will be
as explainable as the dream was with
expert systems for example
i think it's a very complicated question
because i think that
in some ways the question of
explainability is
um kind of very closely tied to the
question of
of like performance like you know why do
you want your system to explain itself
well so
it's so that when it screws up you can
kind of figure out why it did it
right but but in some ways that's a much
bigger problem actually like
your system might screw up and then it
might screw up in how it explains itself
uh or you might have some bug somewhere
so that it's not actually doing what it
was supposed to do so
you know maybe a a good way to view that
problem is really as a problem
as a bigger problem of verification and
validation
um of which explainability is sort of
one component
i see i i just see it differently i see
explainability
you you put it beautifully i think you
actually summarize the field of
explainability
but to me there's another aspect of
explainability which is like
storytelling
that has nothing to do with errors or
with
like the sort of it doesn't it uses
errors
as as uh elements of its story
as opposed to a fundamental need to be
explainable when errors occur
it's just that for other intelligence
systems to be in our world
we seem to want to tell each other
stories and
that that's true in the political world
that's true in the academic world
and that i you know neural networks are
less capable of doing that or perhaps
they're equally capable of storytelling
and storytelling maybe
it doesn't matter what the fundamentals
of the system are you just need to be a
good storyteller
maybe one specific story i can tell you
about in that space is actually about
some work um
that was done by uh by my former
collaborator who's now professor at mit
named jacob andreas
um jacob uh actually works in natural
language processing but he had this idea
to do a little bit of work in
reinforcement learning
and how um on how natural language can
basically structure
the internals of policies trained with
rl and
one of the things he did is he set up a
model that
attempts to perform some tasks that's
defined by a reward function
but the model reads in a natural
language instruction so this is a pretty
common thing to do in instruction
following so
you tell it like you know go to the red
house and then it's supposed to go to
the red house
but then one of the things that jacob
did is he treated that sentence
not as a command from a person but as a
representation of the internal
kind of uh state of the of the of the
mind of this policy essentially so that
when it was faced with a new task
what it would do is it would basically
try to think of possible
language descriptions attempt to do them
and see if they led to the right outcome
so to kind of think out loud like you
know i'm faced with this new task what
am i going to do
let me go to the red house oh that
didn't work let me go to the blue
uh room or something let me go to the
green plant and once it got some reward
i would say oh go to the green plant
that's what's working i'm going to go to
the green plant
and then you could look at the string
that it came up with and that was a
description of how it thought
it should solve the problem so you could
do you could basically incorporate
language as internal state and you can
start getting some handle on these kinds
of things
and then what i was kind of trying to
get to is that
also if you add to the reward function
the convincingness of that story so i
have another reward signal of like
people who review that story how much
they like it
so that you know initially that could be
a hyper parameter sort of hard-coded
heuristic type of thing but it's an
interesting notion
of the convincingness of the story
becoming part of the reward function the
objective function of the explainability
it's in the world of uh sort of twitter
and fake news that might be a scary
notion
that uh the the nature of truth may not
be as important as the convincingness of
the how convinced you are in telling the
story around
the facts
you